if you're looking for some screams to
stream Netflix has quite a few good
options stocked in its library right
about now in addition to some of the
titles everyone already knows about like
it follows the babadook the conjuring
and hush
here are some thrillers horror fans with
a Netflix account won't want to miss
last shift directed and co-written by
Anthony de blase this indie fright flick
follows a rookie cop who's chosen to man
an abandoned police station the night
before it closes for good the place is a
cold winding labyrinth filled with the
eerie hum of fluorescent lightbulbs and
from the moment our hero steps through
the door weird things start happening in
the hallways there's a mysterious phone
call from a frightened girl something is
banging around in the back and the
furniture seems just a little too frisky
things keep getting weirder
especially when the rookie learns the
history of a Manson style family and
their weird connection to this empty
building soon she's running from bloody
specters and horrific visions the horror
never stops until the final bloody
showdown so by the end of last shift
you'll be left mumbling incoherently
right alongside her the nightmare this
2015 documentary is about real-life
terrors which makes it far scarier than
any fictional horror story
the nightmare examines the awful and
upsetting mystery of sleep paralysis a
condition that leaves its victims
trapped in a conscious dream as they see
all sorts of horrible creatures around
them the film features eight people who
suffer from the disorder and they
describe in detail how they can hear the
sounds of the underworld each night and
how they're haunted by demonic shadow
man if that weren't scary enough their
devilish visions are also recreated on
camera giving us a glimpse into the
nightmare world these people experience
let's just say you'll probably want to
stock up on caffeine to stave off your
own slumber after this movie's over
I am the pretty thing that lives in the
house a love letter to gothic fiction
I am the pretty thing that lives in the
house is an atmospheric horror movie
that slowly crawls past the camera like
a Victorian dream a narrator tells us in
the opening minutes that she'll be dead
within the year her name is Lily and
she's a hospice nurse caring for an
elderly novelist in an old house one
full of empty spaces in street
noises which gets even creepier when
Lily glimpses an eerily beautiful ghost
while you don't see any carnage darkness
still permeates the film from its
ominous doorways and suspicious mould to
a disturbing little mystery novel about
a truly terrible incident
thanks to Ruth Wilson's sad and lonely
performance and a creeping sense of
certain doom this is one spooky gem
that'll leave you unnerved and more than
a little worried about what might be
standing right behind you under the
shadow there are plenty of evil spirits
haunting under the shadow but this
Iranian film knows there are scarier
things than demons like the horrors of
war or losing a kid said in Tehran
during the iran-iraq war the film sheds
light on citizens who sought shelter
underground that's the world
our heroine finds herself in as she
tries to protect her kid from bombs and
kidnapping Jim these spirits are drawn
to fear and anxiety looking for
something to possess but as a rational
woman who doesn't believe in myths or
fairy tales she has a hard time
believing these creatures even exist
until she starts seeing floating cloaks
and creepy old men what results is some
genuinely creepy moments that will stick
with you the Transfiguration screen
vampires tend to be either hideous or
completely seductive but Milo from the
Transfiguration stands apart from the
famed crowd this young orphan from New
York streets lives an isolated life
running from bullies visiting a
counselor to discuss violent thoughts
and watching disturbing animal videos
online but Milo is far more than your
typical messed-up kid as he might put it
himself he's a realistic vampire this
boy is obsessed with everything undead
and spends his time stabbing victims and
drinking their blood
despite his thirst for the red stuff
he's not a supernatural being he's just
a mentally disturbed monster without a
doubt the Transfiguration is one of the
most disturbing vampire movies ever made
and features a scene so horrific you
might have to stop watching but despite
the brutality this flick is an original
take on a tired Jon Hren so if you can
stomach some serious gore it might just
transfigure your opinion on vampires
forever the ritual forests or freaky
places and yet few films utilize the
environmental fright factor as well as
the
the film follows four British city
slickers hiking their way through Sweden
when they make the mistake of taking a
shortcut their detour leads them to an
incredibly dense forest where elk are
impaled on trees and something big is
moving in the woods they encounter a
creepy cabin and are plagued with
nightmares that are a little too vivid
meanwhile the thing moving in the woods
keeps getting closer
just as our central hero's guilt over
the violent loss of a friend starts to
take over as the group encounters a cult
symbols and pagan rituals it becomes
apparent that this was the wrong place
for a vacation and we're just as
terrified as the characters when they
stumble upon horror after horror when
they finally come face-to-face with the
thing that haunts them it's one of the
coolest looking monster concepts in
recent former history a dark song far
more than just your typical haunted
house movie a dark song is a deep dive
into the occult a world of angels demons
and complex rituals that have to be
performed in just the right way or else
if magic were real it would look like
this
methodical miserable and absolutely mad
the plot follows a grieving determined
woman named Sophia who's prepared to
spend months locked inside a house with
an angry overbearing magician in order
to move on from her grief she needs to
meet her guardian angel and ask it to
grant her just one wish they're reaching
out to the spirit world is a lengthy
process and if she steps outside the
house even once during the six month
long ritual
she'll jeopardize her soul the magic
rituals are absolutely grueling and as
tempers flare and time loses all meaning
the two characters begin falling apart
until something from the other side
peeks through needless to say if you
delve into black magic things are going
to get dark but if you're in the mood
for a suspenseful slow burn and a horror
movie where the occult feels authentic
and agonizing then you should do your
best to summon a dark song on Netflix
thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our YouTube channel
plus check out all this cool stuff we
know you love to
you
[Music]